okay so I casually mentioned in my last
video about doing like a tech Tuesdays
or a Tech Thursdays and I think I want
to do it on Tuesday because uh I don't
know I think it sounds better no other
reason the first thing that I want to
cover though is the basis fitness watch
I'm absolutely obsessed with fitness
tech and wearable technology in general
but I love the fitness aspect because I
want to be able to quantify exactly what
I'm doing throughout my day getting in
shape is like that you want to do being
able to see that progress actually
motivates you to do better and to keep
going this watch is the basis fitness
watch which we actually covered in my
hardwired show and it's kind of crazy
because a lot of you guys tweeted me and
said that you saw this episode in your
mall oh yeah buddy lit okay Justine I
think you're all warmed up let's move on
to the trapeze all right
so this is the bassist fitness tracker
and it's one of the most advanced health
trackers on the market it has multiple
sensors that allows you to pick up
movement heart rate skin temperature
even perspiration and it all connects to
your smartphone with bluetooth it'll
auto sync to the app which is pretty
easy to navigate so here's some pictures
that you guys have tweeted me that
you've seen my frickin face in your
freaking mall pretty awesome so you're
gonna watch the full episode of that
after this I'll put a link in the
description and also some info on how
you guys can actually win one of these
basis watches from that mall promotion I
don't even know if I'm supposed to tell
you this or not but I'm gonna do it
anyway so call the Union and if you guys
think this is some sort of promo it's
not I bought this watch after we shot
this episode of the show because what I
love so much about this is it tracks
your heart rate which a lot of these
watches don't well they do but you have
to wear one of like the Pooler heart
rate monitors or something around your
chest which is kind of annoying although
I'm actually pretty impressed with this
so far I've been really lazy lately and
I've been traveling a lot so my workout
schedule has basically been non-existent
so thanks they do have a white band I
believe the problem with all of these
accessories all the watches as they just
don't really look that cool I mean it
does look cool for what it is velocity
real its big kind of manly looking it
also tracks your sleep but it's so big I
keep hitting myself in the face at night
but the good thing about it is like I
mentioned the heart rate so how am I
gonna I don't think that's through -
well you can almost see it right now
geez so can you see internet you'll get
the point
so it's gathered in my heart rate right
now 75 I can sync it to my phone with
Bluetooth I don't my device is already
connected I'm gonna have to work on this
presentation a little bit here's the
iPhone app so see yesterday I walked for
493 steps up around 20 collars boy I'm
so fit I'm actually syncing it right now
so sync it up I think sink sink sink
sink some day I was real busy yesterday
I was just walking around shopping I
think I actually got a better workout
shopping
to the gym I'll subtract your sleep
which I actually haven't done because
this thing is kind of big and I
definitely gonna sleep for you liar so I
think the big problem with a lot of
these Fitness watches is there's so many
of them they're not all Universal they
don't all talk together which is one of
the reasons why I actually really love
my Fitbit because there is a big social
aspect there's a community there and a
lot of my friends have them so I'm able
to log in and kind of see what everybody
else has been up to my suggestion to you
guys is don't go out and buy like the
first thing that you see I actually
think this is pretty awesome but there's
so many options out there so go check
them out try them out see what your
friends use because that actually plays
a huge part into my decision why I use
Fitbit a lot is because my sister has it
so I can see oh you're actually doing a
lot of activity maybe I should get off
my butt and do some things also in the
hardwired episode we talked about this
little guy called a misfit which it's
mine's actually sitting over there and I
don't feel like getting it up to show it
to you who but it's okay fine I will
okay in my walk over there I also found
a few other things but this is the
misfit it's super small its sole focus
it basically just looks like a coin
what's great about this is it uses a
watch battery so the battery lasts for a
really long time you don't have to
charge it all the time whereas the basis
and most other watches of this sort
you've got a charge on every night every
other day every couple of days same with
a Fitbit this thing is always on you
just Bluetooth connects to your phone
this video was not supposed to turn into
a really long video talking about all
the stuff but it's all here so I'm gonna
do it anyway
another cool thing that I actually just
found out the other day is misfit now
also works with the Pebble watch so this
is a pebble it's not a fitness focused
watch but you can connect it to your
phone you can get text messages you can
pretty much do whatever you want you can
download apps but there is a misfit
compatible app which is kind of exciting
and on this which actually isn't charged
because I really never used it that much
the Nike Sport watch so it will connect
the GPS it'll track your runs and you
can log on to Nike and you can actually
see and track your runs but you can
actually do that with the iPhone app so
this may be a little bit of overkill but
it does connect with one of the pool or
heart rate
monitors which kind of all brings me
back to the basis why I want to talk
about this one first because it does
track your heart rate I think it also
tracks like your skin temperature and
stuff like that too which is kind of
cool because a lot of these things do
not so here you can see like a little
sensor in the back look at it just doing
its job so really there's so many
options out there that it's honestly
overwhelming and I cannot just sit here
and tell you which one that you should
purchase because there's a ton but what
I can do is show you what I've used when
I like about each and hopefully you guys
can make your own informed decision what
I really would like to know is what have
you guys used because again getting
feedback from people that have
consistently used them whereas the basis
I've used probably for a month so I
definitely went off on some tangents I
don't actually know what I said in this
video but hopefully you guys enjoyed it
nonetheless let me know if you guys have
any suggestions for any other fitness
tech that I should try out because I'm
obsessed I love it and I'd love to be
able to try it out and give you guys my
honest feedback and if you've tried any
of the stuff that I talked about today
especially the basis watch let me know
also check out the description for a
link to my hardwired episode and also
any of the sweepstakes and fill so you
can win yourself a basis and that's all
I've got to say I'm gonna see you guys
later let me check my heart rate first
before I go get my heart rate 6864 hawk
autumns just so fin